this is actually a really interesting  political history moment  bush george w bush was kind of dim  and uh  the thing about him is he's not really  all of it led to trump but he's not  really the pre-trump mold in the sense  that he was actually a neocon bush was a  neocon  palin was kind of the first what i call  sort of like uh  dumacon where it's like you're the main  thing is you don't know anything with  bush he didn't know much but he was  still a neocon at heart  palin was the first sliver of what  eventually was trump and trumpism which  is they're just clueless reactionaries  lacking any real ideology and she was  the late john mccain's running mate in  2008 they fortunately lost to barack  obama and she is now running for  congress